it's very difficult to say what I would
consider it isn't obvious to me that
Andrew Shearer would particularly like
to have me as an official consultant I'm
kind of what might you describe
controversial yes that's the word right
now and so you know it's funny though
because I was making this new video
today which I alluded to earlier using
good old what's this character here
Hitler the Hitler the spokes frog and I
I went back and looked at my comments on
Bill c16 last year which which were the
comments that originally got me in hot
water and had me accused of all the
things I've been accused of transphobia
bigotry racism what else
Oh fascism being on the far right and
then finally and to top it all off
Hitler himself and one of the things
that I realized was that that I was
really calm during that video you
couldn't have really
I couldn't have offered a more
mild-mannered criticism of Bill c16 and
it's pretty funny because you know this
scandal that engulfed wilfred laurier
this week is the worst scandal that I
remember involving a university in in in
my memory going back to the 1970s and
what happened at Laurie it was exactly
what I predicted would happen except it
was actually worse because they did
accuse Lindsay of breaking the law bill
c16 specifically and of contravening the
Ontario Human Rights Code which I you
know for all I know she might have done
so we're at this situation where a TA
showing a video of someone discussing
pronouns in Canada can now be termed a
hate crime and illegal provincially and
federally and like all the usual
suspects have come out of their caves
let's say like Brenda Kaufman the lawyer
I debated last year and said well it's a
real stretch to assume that what Lynn's
a shepherd did was was you know
sufficiently reprehensible to actually
constitute of
violation of the Ontario Human Rights
Commission guidelines policies had says
stretch so I guess we're supposed to
feel good about that but I'm probably a
little bit too hot right now to serve in
any official consultant role that
doesn't mean that I wouldn't be happy to
speak to you know political figures who
might be interested in speaking with me
because you know I generally speak to
people who ask me to speak to them so as
reprehensible as that might be